ก็
สวัสดีค่ะคุณฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนจะโอน
มาพบกับเราสองคนมาหาอีกแล้วในชั่วโมงดี
กินเด้อเอ้อใช่ไหมคะแล้วค่ะคุยกับน้าถ้า
บีกินเนอร์ครูฟ้าบีกินเนอร์ครูฟ้านี้วัน
อะไร
กินวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดีนะวันพฤหัสที่เท่า
ไหร่คะครูฟ้าวันพฤหัสที่ 9 หักเดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะปีพตต
ปี
2564  a  Call ส
2  021 แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันพุธค่ะวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
พุธที่ 8 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีคศ
2  021 ค่ะค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะแค่วันศุกร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่ 15 เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
เมื่อเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพ
ตตปีพศ
2564 ปีค.ศต้ด
วันนี้ก็วันพฤหัสใช่ไหมคะแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงแล้ว
ตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 นค่ะ 03:00 น 03:00 นแล้วเนาะกี่
นาทีคะฟ้า
15:00 น
[เพลง]
24 นาทีค่ะ
15:00 น
24 นาที
เกาะมาเจอกับเราใช่ไหมคะซึ่งวันนี้นะคะ
แล้วก็ตอนนี้เราเนี่ยก็จะคุยเรื่องกีฬากู
ฟ้า
กีฬาก.พไม่ใช่ไหมนักกีฬาอย่างในรูปนี้
เนี่ยกีฬาอะไรคะ
ฟุตบอล
ฟุตบอลฟุตบอลใหญ่ก็จะมีสนามฟุตบอลสมัย
สนามฟุตบอลเราไม่พูดกีฬาแบบนี้วันนี้นะคะ
เราจะพูดกีฬาที่อยู่ในน้ำ
รักน้ำหนูเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำสมัยเล่นที่น่า
เล่นอะไรเล่นบนน้ำเล่นในน้ำนะเราเรียกว่า
กีฬาทางน้ำอันนี้เป็นน้ำนะคะนักเรียน
ทะเลทะเลก็ได้แม่น้ำใช่ไหมแม่น้ำ
เหมือนแม่น้ำมิสซิสซิปปีทำไมเป็นแม่น้ำ
โขงเป็นแม่น้ำ
แม่น้ำเทมส์แม่น้ำมิสซิสซิปปีจากแม่น้ำ
และก็ได้ทะเลน้ำทะเลก็จะมีสนามทะเลนะเรา
เรียกว่ากีฬาทางน้ำใช่ไหมหา
กีฬาทางน้ำกีฬาทางน้ำมีอะไรบ้างคะคิดว่า
นักเรียนรู้จักทุกคนก็คือว่ายน้ำใช่ไหมหา
ว่ายน้ำ Best  Buy  Now
เบสิคเนาะไก่ว่ายน้ำเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำหมาย
เล่นในน้ำว่ายน้ำฟรีสไตล์
อันนี้เลยคะกบกบแล้วก็
กันชียัง
ผีเสื้อเหรอยังไงอ่ะเพื่อออกเห็นเสื้ออ่ะ
เออ
ว่ายน้ำเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำใช่ไหมคะหรือว่าอัน
นี้อันนี้ก็เป็นกีฬาทางน้ำอันนี้อะไรคะ
ก็นึกว่ากระโดดน้ำใส่ผู้ชายเนี่ยต้องไป
ยืนที่นี่แล้วก็โต๊ะทุ่มลงน้ำเรียกกระโดด
น้ำเป็นกีฬาเหรอใช่ค่ะโอลิมปิคบีโอลิมปิค
นี้อะกีฬาทางน้ำหรอกระโดดหนาวขอโทษค่ะ
กระโดดน้ำใช่ไหมคะขาน้ำ
แล้วอันนี้นะคะมีฟ้ากีฬาอันนี้เรียกอะไร
พายเรือใช่มั้ยคะใช่ฉายตัวนี้กำลังพาย
เรือ
ฮะอย่าลืมเลือนโอ๊ยเรืออันนี้เลยอะไรแคน
นูเรือแคนูแมะเรือแคนูใช่มั้ยพายเรือเป็น
เรือแคนนูหรือว่า
เรือ Bike สมัยนิคเรือใบ
ชื่อว่ากีฬาเรือใบนี้นะคะจ่ายค่ะก็จะมีมี
ใบไส้ไหมคะนี่ก็เล่นที่น้ำมันเรือใบ
เป็นกีฬาทางน้ำไม่ว่าจะเป็นเรือแคนนูใช่
มั้ยเหมือนกันอยู่เนาะน่าจะใช่เราแล้วก็
เรือใบ
ดูแลค่ะอยากกินแค่นมเนาะแล้วก็อันนี้ก็
เป็นกีฬาทางน้ำเรียกว่าอะไรครูฟ้ารู้ไหม
คะ
R
ระบำ
ระบำใต้น้ำค่ะจ่ายค่ะระบำใต้น้ำเลย
การเหมือนเต้น
เต้นใช่ไหมคะระบำใต้น้ำเต้นในหนาวเนาะ
เอ้อเออระวังครั้งเนี่ยก็จะมีอะไรไม่รู้
แล้วก็หนีบจมูก
ฉีดจมูกอ่ะเราเรียกว่าระบำใต้น้ำแม่น้ำ
สาขา
อ่ะกีฬาต่อไปอันนี้คิดว่าพัทยาที่บ้านครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยที่พัทยาเนี่ยก็มีครูฟ้าต้องเคย
เห็นอะไรคะผู้หญิงนี่ค่ะ
7  Google ทรายขี่ใช่ไหมขี้ jsd
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
มันมอเตอร์ไซค์
ใช่จะเป็นมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่อยู่ในน้ำ
ฟ้าเคยเห็นใช่ไหมพัทยามีเจ็ตสกีเคยเห็น
เราพัทยามีเยอะมากจะสกีนอาร์เพราะเคยไป
นั่งดูหรออีห่า
มีคนขี่แล้วก็ครูฟ้าใช่หานั่งจะสักกี่นิด
หน่อยอ่านิดหน่อย
สนุกแล้วนะจ่ายเจ็ทสกีก็จะเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำ
หรือว่านี้ครูฟ้ารู้จักไหมคะรู้จักไหมอัน
นี้อะไร
ไม่รู้จักค่ะกูอันนี้เราเรียกว่าสกีน้ำ
สมัยนี้เป็นสกี้ทำไมแต่เป็นสกีที่เล่นใน
น้ำไม่ใช่ภูเขาแต่มันจะมีภูเขา
น้องแล้วก็ประเทศนักเรียนสองสาวอาจจะลบ 10
องศาเซลเซียสสมัยก็จะมีหิมะหิมะหิมะหิมะ
หิมะเยอะๆแล้วก็จะเป็นเล่นสกีน
สกี้ภูเขาแต่นี้ไม่ใช่สกีภูเขาน้องเป็น
สกีน้ำ
เล่นสกีในน้ำนะคะสายขาว่าเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำ
ใช่ไหมก็ต้องเล่นอยู่ในนาก็
คิดว่าอันนี้ครูฟ้ารู้จัก
รู้จักไหม
เหมือนเรือใบไหมไม่เหมือนหรอไม่ใช่
[เพลง]
เซอะเสริมเหรอ
วินเซิร์ฟเอ้อก็ก็วินเซิร์ฟสมัยเป็นกีฬา
วินเซิร์ฟ
คนไทยก็เรียกวินเซิร์ฟนะคะนักเรียนไม่มี
ภาษาไทยคนไทยพูดภาษาอังกฤษว่า
วินเซิร์ฟ
Skin แปลว่าวินเซิร์ฟเนี่ยเวลาเล่นในน้ำ
ใช่ไหมน้ำเนี่ยต้องมีคลื่นเป็นทะเลทำไมก็
ต้องแบบ
โง่มีคลื่นได้เป็นพื่นที่เหมือนขึ้นไหมคะ
เหมือนเป็นทะเลนั้นมีคำถามนะคะทะเลแล้วก็
มีคลื่นเนอะมีคลื่นน่ะคลื่นจะสูงเท่าไหร่
1 เมตรสูงไปไหม
แล้วก็เล่น
วินเซิร์ฟมีลมหรือไม่มีลม
น้องเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำน้องวินเซิร์ฟคิดว่า
อันนี้อาจจะเป็นแถวๆป่ะ
อเมริกาหรือว่าเดนมาร์กสวีเดน
มีมากๆไงในประเทศไทยมีนิดหน่อยว่าทะเลไทย
เนี่ยคลื่นเนี่ยไม่สูง
เตี้ยเตี้ยเตี้ยธนาคารก็เล่นไม่ได้หรอ
หรือสายกะเลาะอันนี้ล่ะครูฟ้ารู้จักไหม
กีฬาอะไร
คนไทยเรียกซื้อสเก็ตไหมอ่ะ
ขอให้มันมีอะไรน้ำในน้ำถ้า Surf  Skate
Skate มันลืมจะมีเลยมันจะเป็นลานสเก็ต
ใช่ค่ะเทอมบ่น่ะแต่ภาษาไทยมีนะคู่ฟ้าภาษา
ไทยยาวมากกระดานโต้คลื่นเอออ่ะหรอใช่
เซิร์ฟบอร์ดเซิฟซิ่งอะไรอย่างเงี้ยค่ะคน
ไทยเรียกกระดานโต้คลื่นใช่ไหมจะมีแพ้นี่
คือคลื่นใช่มั้ยเป็นพื้นทะเลเวลามีลม
คะแนนไม่จบ
ลิกกิ้งนะต้องแข็งแรงมากๆนะกระดาษโตคืนคน
ไทยก็มีคนเล่นเก่งๆอยู่นะค่านี่มี
เป็นกีฬาทางน้ำใช่ไหมคะ
มีอีก 1 อันอันนี้ไม่รู้ครู Fast เนี่ย
เคยเห็นหรือว่าว่ารู้จักหรือเปล่ารู้จัก
ดู
วอลเลย์บอลเหรอไม่ใช่วอลเลย์บอล 1 มันคือ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงเขาเรียกว่าโปรโลน้ำหรือ
โกลว์น้ำสักพักผู้หญิงในโอลิมปิก
ใช่ไหมค่ะเป็นกีฬาโปโลแต่ว่าเป็นโปโลที่
เล่นในน้ำเราก็เรียกว่าโปโลน้ำยากนักนะคะ
ว่าน้ำเนี่ยเวลาเราจะวิ่ง
ยากมาก slow จ่ายทั้งหมดนี้น้องก็เป็น
กีฬาทางน้ำใช่ไหมคะไม่ว่าจะเป็นอะไรคะคือ
ฟ้าว่ายน้ำหาอันนี้นะคะอ่ากระโดดสู่
กระโดด
น้ำแกร่งกระดกน้ำ
น้ำ
ว่าอ่ะอันนี้ก็
พายเรือสายค่ะอันนี้ล่ะคะ
เรือใบน้องเรือใบ
อันนี้นะคะระบำใต้น้ำ
ระบำได้น้ำอันนี้ล่ะคะ
เจ็ตสกีค่ะอ่าอันนี้นะคะ
สกีน้ำนักกีฬาสกิลน้ำแล้วก็อันนี้กีฬา
อะไร
กระดานโต้คลื่น
อันนี้กีฬาอะไรอ่า
เถอะวินเซิร์ฟ 5 แสนแล้วก็สุดท้าย
โปโลหาโปโลโปโลน้ำนักเรียนก็รู้จักกีฬา
ทางน้ำแล้วน้องรู้ป๊ากีฬาว่ายน้ำว่ายน้ำ
ครูบาสระว่ายน้ำได้ไหมคะครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำได้
อ่ะโอเคๆมาเรียนว่ายน้ำมานะคะก็เลยไว้
นั้นโอเค
[เพลง]
กระโดดน้ำราคา
กระโดดน้ำ
ก็กระโดดได้นะ
แต่เป็นกีฬาถ้าเป็นกีฬาเนี่ยจะไม่เก่งจะ
ไม่กินก็โดดน้ำต้องสวยยังไงพี่นางแล้วก็
นิดหน่อยอ่าหนูฟ้าเนี่ยกระโดดแล้วก็ตูมแก
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้แต่คิดว่าครูฟ้าเคยดูใน
โอลิมปิกสมัยโอลิมปิกมีกระโดดน้ำผู้หญิง
ว่ายน้ำได้ไหมคะว่ายน้ำไม่ได้
แอบไม่ได้
งั้นกระโดดน้ำก็ไม่ได้
ไม่ใช่กระโดดตุ้ง
ไว้ได้แต่ดูโอเค
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าพายเรือแคนนูได้ไหมคะพายเรือแคนู
ได้ค่ะโอ้ยหายเป็นวงกลมอันนั้นไม่ได้เอา
ไม่ได้เหรออันนั้นคนไทยบอกไม่ได้เวลาพาย
เรือมันจะ
วนๆ
รอบที่ 1 รอบ 2
แล้วครูฟ้าอ่ะเล่นเรือใบ
ได้ไหมคะเรือใบครูฟาร์มไม่เคยเล่นเรือใบ
ค่ะต่อ
เคยดูไหมเคยดูเรือใบเคยดูเรือใบนิดหน่อย
ไม่เข้าใจก็
เหมือนกันนะแล้วครูฟ้าระบำใต้น้ำที่ว่า
ไม่ได้เนาะหาผู้หญิงน่ะไม่ได้แต่ดูเคยดู
ระบำใต้น้ำมั้ยเคยดูระดับได้น้ำค่ะยัง
อยากแล้วก็ญี่ปุ่นชนะญี่ปุ่นให้เรียกว่า
ใช่ไหมญี่ปุ่นจิงวะ
แฮมโอลิมปิคเอเชียนเกมระบำใต้น้ำ
นั่นแหละ
ครูฟ้าเล่นสกีน้ำได้ไหมคะเล่นไม่ได้ฮ่ะ
สกีดำเล่นไม่ได้ไม่ได้แต่ครูฟ้าเคยนั่ง
เจ็ตสกีค่ะแต่มีขับศ.ไม่เคยขับเจ็ทสกีคน
เนี่ยขับป๊า
แต่ดั้ง
ต้องเฉยๆไม่เคยค่ะโอเคมั๊ยตื่นเต้นมั้ย
เร็วไหมเจ็ทสกีอิงค์เร็วนะแต่ว่ามันสนุก
ค่ะตั้งฟัง
นิดเดียวนิดเดียวอ่านั่งแต่โอเคนะเจตสกี
นั่งแล้วสนุกคิดว่านักเรียนชอบตายแล้วก็
ประเทศไทยมีสมัยพัทยาอย่างนี้มีเจ็ทสกีนะ
ถ้าเราครูฟ้าครูหญิงคิดออกอยากขับเจ็ทสกี
อะไรก็จ่ายเงินแล้วก็เจ็ทสกีคำได้
ผู้อย่างเคย
ไม่เคยเลยไม่เคยไม่เคยไม่เคยกลัวกับ
กลับจุ้มอื้อไม่เอา
กลัวสายแล้วครูฟ้าเคยหน้ากระดานโต้คลื่น
ไหมคะมีกระดาษแล้วก็ครูป๋าที่นี่เคยไหม
ไม่เคยห่าไม่คืนไม่ได้ใช่ไหมกูไปรักไม่
ได้กระดาษส่งคืนไม่ได้ผู้หญิงก็ไม่อร่อย
เนาะนี่ก็ไม่ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงนักกีฬาทางน้ำ
ทางกดแอร์
เวลา S ไม่ได้แล้ววินเซิร์ฟล่ะครูฟ้าเล่น
ได้ไหมเล่นไม่ได้ไม่ได้ประเทศไทยนิดหน่อย
นิดหน่อยทางเก่งนะคะแล้วก็โปโลน้ำราคาครู
บาเล่นได้ไหม
เคยเล่นบอลกับเรื่องนั้นๆน้ำแต่เอาใกล้ๆ
โปโลนะ olo น้ำคล้ายๆใช่ไหมไปไฟล์เต้นบอล
เฉยๆน่าคิดว่าเนอะกีฬาทางน้ำที่ครูฟ้าได้
เล่นได้ก็คือว่ายน้ำแต่สมัยว่ายน้ำมีอีก
หนึ่งยังลืมร้อยอะไรราทางน้ำแต่กูฟ้ากับ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยน่าจะเล่นไม่ได้
อะไรน้ำ
ดำน้ำ
ดำน้ำทำน้ำก็เป็นกีฬาทางน้ำนะมึงต้องเก่ง
ไม่ต้องเรียน
ดำน้ำยากนะใช่ๆๆอันนี้ต้องเรียนหรอต้อง
เรียนต้องมีสติเขตนะคะถึงจะเล่นกีฬาดำน้ำ
ได้
จ่ายนี้ถือว่าแบบนี้ใช่ไหมดำน้ำลงไป
ดำน้ำแล้วก็มีปลาแต่ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิง
เนี่ย
ดำน้ำแบบนี้ใช่ไหมแบบนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกดำ
น้ำลึกยะไม่ได้
ตั้งแต่ครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงจะได้ก็คือสกูบ้า
ไดวิ่งดำน้ำถ่ายเรียกดำน้ำตื้นสมัย
ดำ
ดำน้ำตื้นสมัยดำน้ำตื้นอันนี้เนี่ยไม่
ต้องเรียนใช่ไหมนิดหน่อยนะ
ดำน้ำนะคะคิดว่า
แบบนี้ไหมแบบนี้ใช่ไหมดังน้ำตื้น
คล้ายๆว่ายน้ำแล้วก็ดำน้ำแต่ไม่เคยรับน้ำ
นะคะฟ้าไม่เคยดำน้ำหรือที่นี่อย่างนี้
เนอะดำน้ำตื้นผู้หญิงก็ไม่นะไม่เคยเหมือน
กันแต่ถ้าครูหญิงกับผู้ฟ้าอยากดำน้ำดำน้ำ
ตื้นหรือว่ากูบ้าไดวิ่งเนี่ยโอเคยังไงคะ
อ่าเกาะเท้านี้นะคะเป็นกีฬาทางน้ำไม่รู้
นักเรียนชอบอะไรเล่นอะไรได้ก็คอมเม้นท์
บอกได้ตายใช้กาดส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้อง
ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าเนาะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ